one of the biggest myths that i get from
my clients is that i need to skip meals
and starve in order to lose weight
it's not true
so if you skip meals it's going to have
such a negative effect on your body that
when you do go to sit down and eat
you'll probably over consume that's
laureen kearney one of three dietitians
we brought into our studios
my name is ryan turner my name is nikita
kapoor to debunk 18 of the most common
weight loss myths
the biggest myth that
frustrates me the most is that all
calories are created equally a calorie
is not just a calorie it depends on the
source of your calories whether it's
coming from caloric dense foods or
nutritional dense foods more dense foods
would be more so our cookies our cakes
we can have a cookie that's 100 calories
we'll eat it it'll digest really fast
then it's going to spike our blood sugar
levels where when we start to crash
again we're gonna crave more sugar for
that energy pick-me-up and that can make
you gain weight on the other hand you
can have a banana which is an example of
a nutritionally dense food i get the
question a lot do bananas make you fat
bananas do not make you fat bananas are
a great source of potassium but for
those 100 calories you're also going to
get the fiber and the nutrients that
your body needs in that cellular level
to make sure that you are healthy and
that you're nourished and you definitely
need to nourish your body if you're
trying to lose weight when we are
restricting calories
you are restricting the energy source of
your body you're also restricting the
energy source of your brain and if
that's happening then you know very
primitive protective mechanisms start to
kick into place where your body senses
that as a physiological threat and does
start to shift your metabolic balance to
burn less because it's getting less it's
kind of like a budget right so if you
have a paycheck um and you're running
out of funds you're going to conserve
how much you pay till your next paycheck
your body does the same your body will
jump into this protective physiological
biological mechanism to reduce the
amount of energy you're using which is
why it is hard for people to maintain
weight and starving yourself can also
shrink your muscles you want to make
sure that you're not eating less than 70
percent of your overall
calorie needs if you do that's where not
only are you probably going to feel
extremely hungry and it's going to take
you off of any goals that you're setting
but you're probably going to start
compromising your muscle mass as well
and that's where weight loss is going to
be unhealthy but while the amount of
calories you consume matters the timing
might not
timing of meals is always a big question
everyone comes to me and they kind of
smirk and they think that i'm going to
give them a thumbs up when they say i
don't eat after six o'clock or seven
o'clock and i say oh all right you enjoy
that and they say no and i say well then
maybe eating after is okay because
timing of day is not going to affect
weight loss
calories are what's going to affect
weight loss or body fat loss so if you
eat a bunch of additional calories and
you're in calorie surplus and those are
coming late at night then that's what's
causing something like weighting and
what about eating first thing in the
morning
it depends on the body and it depends on
the person and their relationship with
food for a lot of people me included if
i don't eat a meal i usually feel like
very deprived and it's like i want to
make up for it later
if that happens then that's where we can
add in like a lot of calories personally
i'm a huge advocate of breakfast our
body runs on fuel and food is our fuel
so if we have our breakfast then we feel
we have more sustained energy throughout
the day and if you do choose to eat
breakfast feel free to go for that two
percent yogurt
now fat is incredibly necessary we
should not be afraid of fat we need fat
in the diet fat's going to be necessary
for things like absorbing nutrients like
the fat soluble nutrients like vitamin a
and d and e and k and you also need to
make sure that fat specifically
cholesterol is what's going to help
produce things like your hormones so
things like estrogen and testosterone
growth hormones so we need all those
kind of things not only is fat healthy
but fat-free foods are often loaded with
sugar or salt so if you have a wholesome
product and you're removing the fat of
it it's going to taste completely
different you probably wouldn't even
like it but what they're going to do is
replace that flavor with something else
and usually it's either sodium or sugar
so
with sugar
when we have like a yogurt that has the
fruit at the bottom they're gonna have
way more sugars than if you had like a
two percent greek yogurt and as it turns
out fat isn't the only nutrient you can
keep in your diet and still lose weight
one of the biggest myths i get about
carbs is that you must omit them from
your diet
to lose weight or my body doesn't digest
them well and i have to omit them
because i never lose weight unless i
restrict myself
it's not true and it's just not
sustainable there's almost impossible to
have a no carb diet fruits and
vegetables are known as carbohydrates
and we must get those for their
nutrients why carbs have a bad name
it's because of the simple carbs the
carbs that you see pre-packaged that are
the cookies the cakes the sodas the
potato chips they're called simple carbs
because the chemical structure of them
is usually one to two glucose molecules
put together so when you have like a
small glucose molecule it's easy for
them to break away but with our complex
curbs they are really long chains of
carbon that usually about 18 carbon long
and then by the time that your body goes
starts to break it down it's going to
take a while and that's exactly what we
want because it helps balance our blood
sugar and also that fiber keeps us full
for longer and then also prevents us
from snacking so eat your carbs
definitely eat your curves and eat your
bread bread's delicious it's like one of
my favorite things and she has a pro tip
for finding bread with more complex
carbs read your ingredientness with
bread
it's the
a lot of those mass-produced breads that
are in the bread aisle that are
shelf-stable they can last a month
without getting mold on them and when
you look at the ingredient list it's
probably about 50 ingredients long
they're the ones we want to avoid when
you're getting bread
get the fresh bread that comes from the
local bakery which is usually around the
deli counter area inside and grocery
stores those will have maybe four or
five ingredients it'll mold after two
days but you can preserve it by just
putting into the freezer and take it out
as you need it
and speaking of bread what about going
gluten-free to lose weight gluten-free
for weight loss can be a huge marketing
ploy so with gluten-free there are a lot
of people that do have an intolerance to
gluten or they have celiac disease which
is where the body starts attacking
itself and can deteriorate the body but
there are also people without these
conditions who are looking to
blame something like the gluten without
checking the rest of their diet if you
are
honest with yourself recording your food
checking the ingredients and then you
eat the gluten and you feel the
intolerance then great but a lot of
people will choose to just jump in and
be like gluten is the enemy so most of
us don't need to cut out gluten or fat
or carbs to lose weight but there are
some products better left on the shelf
the diet sodas are terrible with all the
additives preservatives in them and the
hidden sugars a lot of the
added sugars or the synthetic sugars
that are supposed to be great because
they don't release insulin which then
doesn't cause a spike in blood sugar
levels but internally if we don't
stimulate the release of insulin those
sugars the synthetic sugars go to the
liver build up around the liver hinder
the functioning of the liver and then
can lead to non-alcoholic fatty disease
if i'm gonna have a soda which i have
once in a blue moon it will be the real
thing yes there's more sugar in it but
it's something that i don't have on a
regular basis better yet she says drink
water jazz up your water add fruit to it
add some mint or cucumber lemon yes it
will take a little bit for your taste
buds to reset but you're getting so many
nutrients from that water and your body
requires water for it to function
optimally
water is one of the six nutrients that
the body needs and when we're dehydrated
it also mimics the signs of hunger so
people turn to food a lot if they're
dehydrated not realizing that they're
not hungry it's just your body saying
give me some water on thursday and what
about juice
oh juice cleanses
so juice cleanses are like one of my pet
peeves if you're having a juice every
once in a while great you're still
getting the antioxidants out of it
you're still getting the nutrients but
you're removing that fiber and fiber is
key for the body to support gut health
with a lot of juice cleanses they're
hella expensive and we have this
belief that they're going to be better
for our bodies or it's a cleansing
effect of our body
realistically what's happening is that
when you have those juice cleanses
they're mostly coming from like fruit
sugars and then the vegetable sugars
it's a high high amount of fructose in
the body
when the body consumes excess fructose
it has a spasming effect of the gi tract
that can lend to the cleansing effect so
that when we are actually having a
reaction to the high amounts of fructose
in the body
people think it's the cleansing effect
because the marketing employees have led
us to believe that way but
it's not but you would be better
cleansing your body by actually eating
the apple eating the spinach and eating
all the other fruits that are in that
cleanse that would be better for you
because
fiber is our natural detox what it does
is it goes through the body picks up
like excess fat metabolic waste and help
cleanse it out but juice cleanses aren't
the only diet fads that don't often work
intermittent fasting is probably a
question i get all the time it's we can
kind of put in that myth category now it
can restrict calories and at least
temporarily help you lose weight if
you're only allowed to eat food for
eight hours that just gives someone a
lot of structure and that can be very
very helpful you can only get so many
calories in your mouth in that time
on the flip side someone can get a lot
of calories in their mouth during that
time as well so someone can and i've
seen many people do it they've gained
weight through intermittent fasting so
it's not just going to be this quick fix
there's nothing magical to it and the
same goes for many popular diets
so one of the common diets right now
that is gaining popularity is the
ketogenic diet so a lot of people who
are doing that are just eliminating
carbohydrates which is why that's hard
to sustain because your body does need
carbohydrates for a reason to be honest
there's not a lot of research that's
saying that that is something that is
helpful there's maybe a lot of research
in mice models but that hasn't been
transcribed into human studies and while
people have lost weight on keto it's
often not without side effects they're
eliminating whole grains and legumes
certain fruits and vegetables
and really increasing their
fat intake which although fats are
important excess of any nutrient can
cause metabolic changes in your body
that will impact your cardiovascular
health your physical health your
metabolic health so an example would be
patients that we're seeing in the
clinical setting are following ketogenic
diets are seeing weight loss however are
coming with higher cholesterol markers
they are coming with higher ldl markers
they're coming with more
irritable bowel symptoms um they're
coming with more gastrointestinal
discomfort the truth is there's no one
tool that will make you magically lose
weight
i think the most prevalent
concept around health diseases is
biohacking which is this idea that you
can defeat biology you can work around
your
genetic predispositions your metabolic
parameters and that is actually not true
and the reason for that is because you
cannot defeat biology you cannot
hack hunger you cannot hack access to
healthcare you cannot hack motivation
and this idea that you know again
if those results are there you're going
to
be able to feel more satisfied is also
not true so this biohacking works on
this concept and this belief that you
know you can work your way and you know
fix your body and that prescribes to the
social construct that it is up to you to
change that and that's also why most
diets don't work
they're hard to sustain they're hard to
maintain so the results are very
temporary which is why we go back to
something trying something new it's
important to focus on behaviors rather
than outcomes
where you should start is record your
food a simple food log to lose weight
it's really just being honest with
yourself
identifying your foods and the hidden
ingredients that could be contributing
to excess of hundreds and hundreds of
calories per day take olive oil olive
oil is great but when we cook with it we
usually free pour it into a pan
each tablespoon of olive oil has 128
calories now if you're pouring in like
six seven eight tablespoons with your
vegetables you're getting almost like a
thousand calories that you don't need so
pro tip for cooking with olive oil put
it in wait to your pot your pan is hot
once it's hot add one to two tablespoons
of olive oil
and then add in your vegetables when the
pan is hot enough it will disperse
easier and then you use less
also once you put the vegetables in some
water and moisture will come from those
vegetables and will add to the liquid in
the pan so you actually don't need to
add excess in and if you are being
mindful of what you eat that whole idea
of cheating kearney isn't a fan i don't
think there is any cheap meals i don't
like the word cheat i think it gives it
this
it gives us this like higher power like
oh this is really bad and you know i
can't believe i did this i completely
fell off the wagon no remove that
because then you're gonna want it more
you're gonna feel even more guilty about
it if you go out you're socializing
you're trying out one of new york's like
best restaurants that's filled with
cream and butter
enjoy it just try to get a salad to
start and filling up on salad is a great
way to cut the calories and then
have like one of the appetizers that are
not in line with your health goals with
your table and share because sharing is
caring and there's more good news
you can still lose weight while drinking
occasional alcohol
if you're sticking to the cleaner foods
and by omitting all the foods that you
tend to enjoy in the past by emitting
alcohol trying to increase your exercise
and then doing this like
detox fudge all in one go it's
overwhelming and it's setting you up for
failure so doing it in stages and being
more realistic about what you can change
now and then work towards it well what i
usually recommend to my clients is take
care of your food now if you understand
how your body feels when it's nourished
understand like how your gut health is
supposed to be supported and then we'll
focus on alcohol and working in the
exercise but the thing is no matter how
much we care about it weight definitely
isn't everything i think one of the
biggest myths around weight loss and
weight is that overweight equals
unhealthy on normal weight equals
healthy as defined by the bmi category
bmi is a very inaccurate measure of
health because it is just looking at
your height and weight
without taking into account what your
metabolic factors and parameters are
what is your physiological health your
physical health your sleep your mental
health
your relationship to food
you know and i think it's very important
to factor those things if you really
want to define someone you know as
healthy and if we're not going to look
at it more holistically
i think what that does is it
marginalizes people in bigger bodies
plus not everyone can lose weight even
if they're putting in the same effort
that's a very common myth that everybody
should have should has the same ability
to lose weight and if everybody eats the
same way they're going to look the same
way which is very untrue and that's
incorrect and the reason for that is i
think it's important to understand that
someone's weight is a factor of so many
different things it is so
complex all the way from your genetic
predispositions your past your family
history your past medical history
your
you know relationship to food as you're
growing up because not everybody has
access to food because health is about
inclusion access
connection joy physiological well-being
and we have to take those factors into
account